did you swing over the vacation no oh
wow
come on let's concerts is everything in
New York happens in a small window
because of the cold here no so concert
season comes up and and swings out the
window
don't you concert and swing well you got
to go to two nights of Iron Maiden when
they show up right
okay multitasking we hug out over the
break what you guys do yeah each other
well we're both big fans of soccer yeah
and there was a big soccer game in town
Yankee Stadium and I invited him I got
tickets and I invited him to come with
me so I went with him I wasn't sure he
doesn't go how do you have you allowed
out of the house surely to do stuff like
that he's got kids and everything she's
cool and she's like Wonder Woman do it
with Brent out to soccer game you know
I'm not going to Brent to a [ __ ] club
I'm going and so I wrote I've made up
two sides because I know I have a friend
that works in Yankee Stadium who works
the camera for the big screen so I wrote
two sides I snuck in with me that said
liar with an arrow point to either side
cuz I didn't know which side was gonna
sit on yeah so we're sitting there
watching the game so bad my friend text
me goes hold the sign up now and I held
the side up it said liar and I was
pointing to Brent yeah oh my did you no
no this is the first I'm hearing and you
think he's a liar because he's lying
about his sex club yeah yeah can you
imagine he did that what an [ __ ]
no he invites you to a game he was you I
bought him a beer right it was nice to
get a free ticket to the game we get to
see like a big-time English soccer team
but he was using you to do you got to
see the picture I got a screech he
doesn't even know I did it because he
was videotaping I was taking what was
going on the field he was taking a
picture of the field he was having a
good time feeling all close to you how
much stupid yeah yeah
oh sorry ik [ __ ] God he's such an
[ __ ]
you